han pasado ocho décadas pero el
levantamiento del gueto de Varsovia
sigue vivo en las memorias catalogado
como un acto Heroico cientos de jóvenes
judíos se enfrentaron directamente a las
fuerzas de adolf Hitler sin ningún tipo
de ayuda Armada
estoy muy feliz de ver a tanta gente
joven aquí es muy importante que venga
la gente joven que la gente sepa lo que
pasó aquí que entiendan que esta
terrible historia no se puede repetir
cada año miles de personas de todo el
mundo participan en una marcha para
conmemorar los hechos del 19 de abril de
1943 el día en que los habitantes del
gueto de Varsovia decidieron enfrentarse
a las tropas alemanas para evitar su
deportación masiva a campos de
Exterminio una rebelión que duró tres
semanas y en las que más de 56.000
judíos Fueron exterminados por los nazis
el gueto de Varsovia fue establecido por
la Alemania nazi en 1940 un área de 3
kilómetros cuadrados donde vivían unos
450.000 judíos la mayoría de los cuales
fueron enviados a Campus de Exterminio o
asesinados en el propio gueto
Cristina boonica de 93 años la última
judía polaca sobreviviente tenía tan
solo 11 años cuando fue Testigo Del
levantamiento luego de pasar ocho meses
encerrada en un búnker para sobrevivir
ningún niño en el mundo merece tal
destino ciertamente sobreviví pero mi
vida no fue nada fácil huérfana sin
hogar analfabeta porque no fui a la
escuela en el momento en que debería
haber ido Por qué Tuve que pasar por
todo esto porque un tipo como Hitler no
estaba feliz de que un niño judío
estuviera vivo y pensó que debería ser
asesinado pero vivo para su disgusto
la explosión de la gran sinagoga de
Varsovia fue el hecho que marcó el fin
de levantamiento y la destrucción
definitiva del gueto el 16 de mayo de